il a dans le cadre dans le cadre de nos
soirées culturelle Roger perfit vous
proposeécouter maintenant les résultats
de notre hit parade des siècles alors
nous avons en numéro 1 du 17e siècle un
morceau de musique légère pour les
plaisirs du roi dit pass à caille pour
lutte viol au bois et Flut à bec de
Jean-Baptiste lulie Marlena morceau
commandé par Louis X à l'intention de sa
favorite la très belle lad
marbelade
[Musique]
voulez-vous coucher avec moi ce soir
voulez-vous coucher avec
moi voulez-vous coucher avec moi ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi numéro 1 du 18e siècle et bien c'est
la BWV numéro 8 pour le 6e dimanche
après la Trinité de Willy Rigo Sébastien
4at rossan mon âme s'enflamme avec la
chale des enfants de ch sous la
direction de Claude
[Applaudissements]
car ce soir les visages les lumières
dans l'église VI
rvolteosos ce soir les pèlerins vont
faire chanter les cœurs et faire leur
dévoaution et toi dans la foule tu m ta
beauté nous
survolte on Scand ton nom magnifie
encore c'est le
grand pardon
r
[Musique]
r lorsque ton corps se
balance la possession
s'avance
quand je vois tes
jambes mon âme
senflam j'ai choisi de vivre avec
[Musique]
toi et enfin au numéro 1 du 19e siècle
un extrait du célèbre opéra Madonna
Madonna d'alinchamp Fortini le grand
terre du bébé chanteur Allegro
maropo s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu chantes trop tu aimes trop les hommes
et la
vie mon bé chanteur tu chantes dans les
bras de qui te trouve jolie mon mon
bé sur la ville quand vient le soleil
c'est difficile ma foi belle est fidèle
alors adieu mon cœur adieu mon bébé
chanteur imagine quee on est tous les
deux on était pas fait pour être heureux
on avait rien en
commun toi tu vivais dans ton
[Musique]
coin la vie la vi elle est Jalu tu lui
ches en C cur mon béé chanteur et des
principes tu n'en as jamais eu
beaucoup oh si d' âge on a pas toujours
les mêmes idées sur les choses de
l'amour alors adieu mon cœur AD Dieu mon
bébé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chanteur